248 milliards d'euros s'élèvent qui a
été octroyé par les banques françaises
aux énergies fossiles depuis l'adoption
de l'accord de paris en 2015 selon le
rapport annuel d'un groupement des ong
d'oriflame finances
après les beaux discours sur le climat a
placé la réalité celle à la course sans
relâche aux énergies fossiles et pour
cause selon ce même document 60 banques
à travers la planète ont accordé pas
moins de 3200 milliards d'euros aux
entreprises actives dans les énergies
fossiles comme le charbon le gaz ou
encore le pétrole et ceux ci entre les
années 2016 et 2020 une tendance à la
hausse
aux antipodes des belles promesses
faites en marge de l'accord de paris sur
le climat la france ne fait donc pas
exception et se place même en haut du
podium avec une hausse de 19 % par an
entre 2016 et 2020 atteignant même 72
milliards d'euros dead
l'an dernier il n'en fallait pas moins
pour s'attirer les foudres des
écologistes et dans leur viseur un
établissement bancaire en particulier
bnp paribas la banque française qui a
déboursé 35 milliards d'euros pour ces
filières en 2020 soit une hausse de 41 %
faisant d'elle le plus grands financeurs
européen devant et là aussi cocorico la
société générale et le crédit agricole
au bal des hypocrites bnp paribas est
roi pendant qu'elle se joignait aux
appels publiques en faveur d'une relance
verte à la suite de l'éclatement de la
crise du coc vite 19
bnp paribas signé aussi loin des
projecteurs des chèques de plusieurs
milliards de dollars sans condition
super majors pétrolières et gazières
c'est un jour de honte pour la finance
française soit 10 en pointe sur le
climat mais le groupe financier se
défend arguments l'urgence de la
situation face au co vie 19 tous les
secteurs de l'économie ont eu besoin de
soutien bnp paribas a moins soutenu le
secteur pétrolier et gazier que les
autres secteurs d'activité
bnp paribas natixis et jp morgan ou
encore bank of america
nombreux sont les établissements de
crédit à être partie prenante d'un
business qui demeure très juteux
l'écologie peut donc encore attendre